- You look stunning.
- Thank you.
- We went colorful.
- Yeah.
- Both of us today.
I like it.
How are you?
- I'm so great now that I'm here.
- Oh my gosh!
That was, you're a badass.
- I don't know who that was.
- I was like, that's, I'm afraid.
- Well, wait, the last
time your husband was on,
well, when, I shared my
disgusting Doritos thing
that went viral apparently.
But it's, I like this cheese not the chip.
Whatever.
But he showed a video.
He judged me for it too.
He showed me a video of your oldest
talking like a ladies' man.
So let's see this again.
- We're starting off at soft number one.
Shouldn't be too bad.
Okay.
- What's up ladies?
- I think he is trouble.
He's gonna be trouble.
What's up ladies?
How's that going?
- He's he has taken a
little bit of a sabbatical
from having a crush world.
- Oh really?
- Yes.
Because the first crush
he had the second crush
and the third crush, they
all ended up moving away.
- Oh, no.
- Yeah.
So he feels like,
he would say to me,
I heard him like say, he's like
you know, "Mom, what do
you think it is about me?
That every time I get a crush
on somebody, they move away."
And I was like,
"Well, honey I think it's just bad luck."
And he was like,
"I think I should just take a break.
I'm not gonna get a crush for a while."
- Oh buddy.
- I know.
Really sad.
- Are you nervous about your kid?
Your kids are teenager.
So they dating?
They're teenagers.
If I say anything about any of
this they'll have me killed.
- I was like, shh.
- So you're open with your boys
about when you and Sterling
have disagreements, right?
So a lot of people will
tell you not to do that
in front of your kids,
but I love because I read why y'all do it.
Can you tell everybody why you-
- Yes.
I do it because of who my older kid is.
He's a very intuitive,
very empathetic kid.
And he picks up on a lot of things.
And still waters run deep with that guy.
Like, he'll take something
and he'll germinate
and he'll think about
it and he'll ruminate
and he'll make it into
something that it's not.
And if you don't give him the
safety net to ask questions
and to get his fears addressed,
it can really veer into really
tough territory for him.
And like I read somewhere that trauma
is not the thing that happens to you.
It's not having the space
to discuss the thing
that happened to you.
You know?
And so I kind of feel with him that like
I just want him to know
that he can ask me,
any and obviously it's age appropriate.
You know, I don't talk to him
like I talk to a girlfriend.
But like, you know,
I try to put things in
such a way that he knows
when I say you're safe,
he can believe me when I say you're safe.
Because, you know what I mean?
- I like that.
They also see y'all maybe
disagree about something
but you work through it.
Because lot of times,
you know, adults will disagree
about something in the house
and then you'll go to your room
and then you'll figure it out
but the kids never got to see the that.
And so that is kind of
interesting for relationships
in the future.
Like to be able to work
through that, know how.
- Right?
And to show people,
because you can say
compromise all you want to
but what does that mean to a,
you know, that doesn't mean anything.
It has to be modeled.
- I'll tell you, and it's a shock,
like even with my divorce
we never fought in front of our kids.
We didn't really fight too often.
But I just mean like, we
never did anything like that
and I think announcing a
divorce to them was like, what?
Because we were so,
because I saw,
I think too much as a
kid, so I didn't do any.
I was like, no, no, no, no.
We not gonna do any of
that in front of them.
I don't want that baggage on them.
But then it was kind of just
a much of a shock though
because we didn't say anything, you know?
- Yeah.
So that's, it's kind of hard
to know which thing to do.
I guess it depends on the child.
But I love the lesson though.
I never heard parents
really talk about that.
And I think it's really
cool for specific kids.
Like that's probably really
helpful to work through,
and I'm gonna take that
advice and go home with it.
- I hope so.
Let's talk about your new show though.
It's called the End Game.
So what's it about?
Because you play badass.
I like it.
- You know, FBI agents
are very specific people
and you know, God love them.
Because you have to put your country
and your job pretty much before
anything and everybody else.
And they do that for us.
They do that to keep us safe.
You know, the armed
services, the CIA, the FBI
- It's a sacrifice for
the family has to be hard.
- It's hard.
It's really hard for them, you know?
So it's an honor to be able to like go
into that world.
And obviously this is a heightened
and explored version of that.
You know there's this,
I call it this sort of Carmen Sandiego
criminal mastermind.
- Oh my god!
I loved that you said Carmen Sandiego.
Where in the world is she?
- Well you know,
she's, she's on our show.
We found her and she's lovely.
And she's on our show.
And she's, you know,
it's like who's bad, who's not?
Is she bad?
Is she not?
Is she like working for greater good?
Is she only working for herself?
And I'm the only one that
actually has any Intel on her.
So I become the sort of centerpiece
of this investigation.
- That's so fun.
What a cool show.
- It's a really cool show
- Yeah.